Having your economic needs as being
higher than dealing with this unsettled
scenario.
Yeah.
Like being at work and fulfilling the
needs of the attached to the sides of you
by your superior,
then you still have,
you still get to survive.
So get to easily to have
a roof over your head,
but you just have to sort of deal
with the consequences of this.
Like Ben settle.
Well,
I mean,
look,
I would say sometimes people are put into
positions that unsettled them and they
don't know what to do.
You know,
they're kind of,
they're screwed if they do this and
they're screwed if they do that and that's
all they can see,
the dude and people get put
no situations all the time.
But I'm not really going to talk about
those except that people really suffer
for that.
You know?
Um,
partly what Rogers is talking about
is a form of optimal organization,
right?
So it's to be considered
as the final goal.
In some sense.
It's what you're working towards.
I think it's very difficult
to live in a way that you,
so that you never encounter
contradictions as you move forward.
In fact,
that's precisely what does
happen as you move forward.
And it's up to you on the fly to argue,
to organize your response to those
contradictions in a manner that doesn't
destabilize the entire structure.
But you know,
the entire structure is a
strange thing because again,
Rogers Rogers has got a psychoanalytic,
well,
it's not exactly right.
It's complicated.
Okay?
The hierarchy that Roger's describes
this characteristic of the self,
this is something he
doesn't discuss that much.
The hierarchy that you make of yourself
is not independent of the way that you
fit into hierarchies in the world.
So really by hierarchically re organizing
yourself at the same time you're
hierarchically organizing the world.
And so part of the problem is,
is that if you destabilize yourself or
if you've come up with a sub optimal
solution,
there's a,
there's a twist there that's going to,
it's going to follow you up.
Now,
it may be the best that you've got.
Sometimes that happens,
you know,
I'm not saying you can always solve
a problem in an optimal manner,
you know?
Do you remember the movie Sophie's choice?
You can never see that.
It's an old movie.
MMM Sophie.
It's a movie about that,
about Germany during the Nazi period,
she had to choose which of her two
children was going to be shocked.
Well,
you know,
it's pretty hard to
come up with an optimal.
So let me shift to that.
All right.
So
Roger's though didn't really think that
that actual problems in life constituted
psychopathology.
That's sort of more of the existentialist,
although he had an existential quit,
he was thinking more that what constituted
psychopathology per se instead of
just plain ordinary suffering was the
contradictions that arose because people
fail to use their potential for
articulation in a manner that continually
fostered their integration.
So he would say,
well to the degree that you are
going to use instrumental language,
it's not a term he used,
but it's a good summary of,
of his philosophy that you were
bringing to bear on yourself,
unnecessary and others around you.
Unnecessary pain and suffering.
And that was psychopathological.
It's psychopathological because it's
unnecessary because in principle it could
be avoided.
So,
so that's the idea.
And so the idea as well is that the
organizing principle that brings you into
this optimally functioning hierarchy is
your commitment to truth to accurately
represent what it is that you experience.
And that's again,
you know how Piaget talked about the
fundamental truth as a process rather than
as a state or a fact.
It's the case for Rogerian
phenomena phenomenology as well.
And you could kind of understand that
because of course therapists are dealing
with people,
living people and life is a process,
not a state.
And so Rogers was concentrating
very much on the process,
which he regarded as absolutely
crucial and believed that the process,
the process properly implemented
would bring about the best possible
organization.
And then we'll update that
organization has necessary too.
So it's a radical idea.
But I would also say that it's
fundamentally rooted in his Protestant
Christianity because one of the tenants
of Christianity is that the word orders
chaos.
And so that idea was lurking at the
bottom of Roger's conceptual structure and
you know,
he was intelligent enough to
articulate it fully in a modern way.
That's still where it came from.
Okay.
Now it's an older idea of,
of Christianity.
So.